[Music]
she's the hands of time she's the queen
of kings
[Music]
Keith Urban is making a statement with
his new single female and this female is
here for it hey there I'm Silvia lacy
welcome back to certified country today
is all about Keith and his next album we
talked about it when I saw him in
Nashville back in October coincidentally
on the same week that he wrote female as
a response to the Harvey Weinstein
scandal that rocked Hollywood now Keith
wasn't spilling details about that song
specifically but he did open up about
his process and what we can expect on
the rip Court follow-up more importantly
though he talked about how to craft the
perfect love song for wife Nicole Kidman
but first I'm gonna pull back the
curtain for a minute and show you guys
what it can really be like we are trying
to get an interview done on the fly in
this case Keith and I were talking in an
active rehearsal space for the CMT
artist of the Year event and by active I
mean that Chris Stapleton's Band was all
over that sound system take a look at
that alright that kick drum really
sounds awesome it's live live talking
between rehearsals this is real yeah
absolutely
this is when I asked the folks running
the event if we could kindly get a few
minutes of quiet nope we could not now
we got to talk about what's coming up
next after rip court are you working on
new music I am yeah I have been the
better part of this year really really
since January January February yes
starting to piece an album together what
can you tell me about it like what's
inspiring you and what's kind of the
vibe for this next project I think
that's it it's feeling in its vibe it's
it's always about the spirit of a record
you know I think this songs that end up
on an album for me are the ones that
seem to all be in unison with a
particular spirit that's happening with
a record you know rip cord definitely
had that feeling of the spirit this
album will have this you know a spirit
of its own a vibe man can you give me
any teaser on timeline I've no idea no
idea no idea when it happens to happen
yeah because I caught a lot of songs
like this one you digging this one the
vibe is on the new record it's it's
called intrusive drums it's got a good
groove
[Music]
I want to know what are the keys what
are like the three steps to making a
really great club some honesty that's it
that's one step that's it yeah honesty
and vulnerability we're just best
friends as well as married you know that
we're everything if I were a pain I
wouldn't change it juice paint you Brad
now last one before I let you go with
all the awards that you've been
receiving throughout your career what's
left on the bucket list for you what are
you still hoping to achieve I guess I
just think of it in terms of just
getting better at what I do
that's always been they go you know it's
that's it that hasn't changed since so I
give you like climbing mountains when
you get to the top you find another
mountain because you like climbing
mountains not so much being on the top
one just climbing them that's what I
like doing the next night Keith and
Nicole hit the red carpet together and I
got to ask mrs. urban what she thinks of
her hobbies new music what do you think
of what he's cooking up I'm dancing
around the living room to it already
you're ready for the album to be out
yeah yeah I'm always ready for new music
these songs have been permeating our
house for a year now so I'm anxious to
get new music out with them and we work
them and I and now I sort of I hear how
they change and it's really fascinating
yeah he's such a I mean a maestro you
know when are we gonna get a duet with
you two
listen we've all seen Moulin Rouge we
know Nick can sing so I say show up
those pipes baby girl we're ready for it
all right well I hope you had a lovely
and relaxing Thanksgiving but now that
it's December first we are heading into
full-blown holiday mode and in that
Christmas spirit next week I am going to
be counting down some of my favorite
country songs of the season but I need
your help head over to the community tab
right here on e t--'s YouTube page or a
comment below and let me know your
favorite country Christmas songs then
come back and see us next Friday to see
if your picks made it into our show
don't forget to click the link and ring
the bell in the description below so you
never miss an episode of certified
country
[Music]
[Music]